Act now.
>> WHAT YOU ARE SEEING NOW IS
INHUMANE.
IT IS A HORRIBLE SITUATION.
NOBODY HAS SEEN WORSE OR
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND THEY SHOULD
FINISH THE WALL.
>> Bill: FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
HITTING BACK AFTER PRESIDENT
BIDEN BLAMED HIM FOR THE
CURRENT BORDER CRISIS.
BIDEN SAYS HE MAKES NO
APOLOGIES FOR ROLLING BACK
TRUMP IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
HE ALSO DENIED THAT MIGRANTS
ARE COMING TO THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE HE IS A NICE GUY.
SENATOR TED CRUZ IS LEADING A
DELEGATION OF REPUBLICAN
SENATORS AT THE BORDER TODAY.
HE POSTED THIS VIDEO TO TWITTER
EARLY THIS MORNING.
>> THE OTHER SIDE OF THE RIVER
WE HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO AND
SEEING CARTEL MEMBERS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS RIGHT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE RIVER WAVING
FLASHLIGHTS, YELLING AND
TAUNTING AMERICANS, TAUNTING
THE BORDER PATROL.
>> Bill: LET’S BRING IN BRANDON
JUDD FROM THE BORDER COUNCIL.
HE JOINS US BY PHONE ON DONNA,
TEXAS, A FACILITY OVERWHELMED
WITH MIGRANTS NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
GOOD TO TALK TO YOU AGAIN.
HOW IS IT GOING DOWN THERE WITH
THIS DELEGATION OF REPUBLICANS
AND WHAT ARE THEY SEEING?
>> I’M GLAD THEY GOT TO SEE
WHAT THEY DID LAST NIGHT.
WE WERE THE ONES THAT TOOK THEM
OUT TO THE BORDER.
SENATOR CRUISE AND THE REST OF
THE SENATORS TO THE BORDER AND
SHOWED THEM WHERE THE CROSSINGS
ARE TAKING PLACE AND SMUGGLERS
WERE AND SURE ENOUGH THEY WERE
SO AUDACIOUS THEY CAME TO THE
BANK OF THE RIVER AND TAUNTING
US AND MAKING FUN OF US AND
SAYING WE COULDN’T DO ANYTHING
TO STOP THE CROSSINGS THAT WERE
TAKING PLACE.
THESE PEOPLE WERE GOING TO COME
REGARDLESS.
SO THEY GOT A REAL WORLDVIEW OF
WHAT WE DEAL WITH ON A DAILY
BASIS.
AND NOW THEY ARE IN THE ACTUAL
PROCESS IN THE FACILITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID NOBODY HAS
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
I WAS HERE IN 2014 AND SAW WHAT
TOOK PLACE IN 2014 IN THESE
PROCESS FACILITIES AND WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2019 AND I CAN TELL
YOU PERSONALLY THAT WHAT WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW IS HORRENDOUS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY INHUMANE THE
WAY THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING
PACKED IN THESE FACILITIES.
IT IS JUST LIKE SARDINES.
THERE IS NO ROOM TO SEE THE
FLOOR.
THEY ARE PACKED IN THERE SO
TIGHT LAYING ON THE GROUND.
SO YEAH, EVERYTHING THAT YOU
ARE HEARING, THE REPORTING
THAT’S COMING OUT OF HERE BY
THESE SENATORS THAT ACTUALLY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE TRUTH IS,
IT’S ALL ACCURATE AND IT SHOULD
REALLY UPSET THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
I HOPE IT DOES.
>> Bill: HOW DO YOU KNOW THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE TAUNTING LAST
NIGHT?
WHAT WERE THEY TAUNTING AND HOW
DO YOU KNOW WHO ARE JUST
FAMILIES BEING BROUGHT ACROSS
BY ACTUAL SMUGGLERS, HOW CAN
YOU TELL?
>> WHEN WE’RE DEALING WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENT MYSELF AND SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN DOING THIS FOR 23
YEARS, YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING TO THE ACTUAL SMUGGLERS
THE WAY THEY TAUNT YOU.
THEY WERE BRINGING DOWN THE
FAMILY UNITS AS WE WERE SITTING
THERE TRYING TO SHINE OUR
FLASHLIGHTS ON THEM.
AGAIN WHEN THEY ARE TELLING US
I CAN’T SPEAK ON AIR EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WERE SAYING BECAUSE
IT WAS FILLED WITH CURSE WORDS
BUT THEY WERE TELLING US WHERE
WE COULD GO SHOVE IT.
THESE WERE THE ACTUAL SMUGGLERS.
IT IS VERY CLEAR WHO THEY WERE.
WHEN THESE WEREN’T THE FAMILY
UNITS.
FAMILY UNITS DON’T TALK TO US
THAT WAY.
THEY’RE GIVING UP BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY’LL GET RELEASED
ULTIMATELY.
>> Bill: I WANT TO PLAY THIS
FROM THE NEWS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY.
THIS IS PRESIDENT BIDEN TALKING
ABOUT THE MIGRANT SURGE AND
SAYING THAT IT IS JUST NORMAL
WHAT WE’RE SEEING.
WATCH THIS.
>> President Biden: LOOK, I
GUESS I SHOULD BE FLATTERED
PEOPLE ARE COMING BECAUSE I’M
THE NICE GUY.
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING
TO THE BORDER IN THE WINTER
MONTHS OF JANUARY, FEBRUARY,
MARCH.
IT HAPPENS EVERY YEAR.
THE REASON THEY’RE COMING IS
THAT IT’S THE TIME THEY CAN
TRAVEL WITH THE LEAST
LIKELIHOOD OF DYING ON THE WAY
BECAUSE OF THE HEAT IN THE
DESERT.
>> Bill: THE NUMBERS TELL A
DIFFERENT STORY.
TOTAL ENCOUNTERS AT THE BORDER
LAST MONTH FEBRUARY WERE UP
177% YEAR-OVER-YEAR.
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS WERE BY
ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT, BRANDON.
ONE OF THE -- FIRST OF ALL
ANSWER THAT.
HE DIDN’T GET ANY PUSHBACK.
NO REPORTER SAID ONLY 13% OF
THE FAMILIES ARE BEING SENT
BACK AND THE NUMBERS INDEED ARE
A LOT HIGHER.
>> NO, I’M GLAD THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE FACT
CHECKING.
EVEN LIBERAL MEDIA OUTLETS ARE
FACT CHECKING HIM BECAUSE WHAT
HE IS SAYING IS SO OUTRAGEOUS.
I’M SO THANKFUL THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS -- I’M NOT TRYING
TO GIVE YOU CUD OWES, LIKE FOX
NEWS TO TELL THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WHAT THE ACTUAL TRUTH IS.
IF WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THE TRUTH
IS WE CAN’T FIX THE PROBLEM.
DEFINE THE PROBLEM SO YOU CAN
FIX IT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT
SITTING UP THERE SAYING I GUESS
I’M A NICE GUY IT IS
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO VIOLATE
OUR DAYS.
IF WE DO THAT WE’RE NO BETTER
THAN THE COUNTRIES THESE PEOPLE
ARE COMING FROM.
>> Bill: BEFORE I LET YOU GO
THIS STRUCK ME.
YESTERDAY PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
SOME FAMILIES ARE NOT GOING
BACK BECAUSE MEXICO IS REFUSING
TO TAKE THEM BACK.
SOME, NOT ALL.
WE’RE IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH
MEXICO.
THAT WILL CHANGE.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE GOING BACK.
SO THAT SEEMS VERY ODD TO ME
BECAUSE A, HE SAID YOU SHOULD
COME.
HE TOLD EVERYONE YOU SHOULD
COME IF YOU’RE FACING
OPPRESSION IN YOUR TON TREE.
HE ALSO HAS UNDONE THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO PLAN.
THAT STATEMENT SEEMS CONFUSING
TO ME BASED ON WHAT HE SAYS HIS
POLICY IS.
>> COMPLETELY AND TOTAL
CONTRADICTORY.
POLITICAL RHETORIC.
HE SHOULD HAVE KEPT THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY IN PLACE.
HE DIDN’T.
HE IS THE ONE WHO INVITED THIS
PROBLEM THAT WE’RE CURRENTLY
DEALING WITH.
>> Bill: A BIG PROBLEM ON THEIR